a message for the fans because people
have stayed with you it's been a
difficult year and a half for you in
your life how how has it been it's been
difficult but I've known all along that
I had an enormous support and so
therefore it's been a very helpful thing
for me it's difficult to explain how it
felt but now I feel fantastic and I'm
here back doing what I normally do and
it's just a wonderful feeling we've read
the newspapers the last week or so
you're now taking legal action against
the police so the orchard police and the
BBC I can't speak about that we're in
litigation is so therefore I have to
decline answering how hurtful were those
allegations I can't really talk about
this anymore because I've already spoken
about it and I'd rather not waste of
time I'd rather talk just about the
positive aspect of life that I feel now
myself and to be part of a show that is
also full of British positive thoughts
so I feel really great this is all part
of my therapy and so far I'm coming out
of it really well can I ask a clip
you're a man of faith was there a moment
when your faith was tested in the past
year and half never not once and if it
wasn't for my face I don't know how
people cope without a faith I've lent on
my faith for two years and it's been I
wouldn't have it any other way no no my
faith stayed strong and now it's
struggle feel being invited tonight to
present an award so many inspirational
British stories in that building your
highness tonight well I mean it's always
good to be part of something like this
I've been involved in various charities
over the year just being able to give
back is enough but sometimes it's really
good to go that one inch further where
you actually take part in something that
has nothing to do with you and I said
earlier this is about real people in
Britain who do really fantastic things
so for me it's an extra bonus to be I
feel privileged actually to have been
asked to come and present an award to
someone who's doing and it has done
something really wonderful so absolutely
fabulous for me so you're back I'm back
you're back
so many celebrity voila famous friend
along the tonight I'm sort of like
Guardian denizer Laurier just tell us
what a wonderful man your own words how
gossiping well I've known clear for
forty five years and right from the very
beginning I knew that cliff was clear
because he was a very good man and I've
known that for a long time but obviously
it has been very difficult for cliff
over the last couple of years and along
with many friends of his we've supported
him the way that you would respect
offender support and it was the best
news of all when everything was cleared
and I loved the fact now that Clippers
back in this country to promote what he
does what he's done so brilliantly since
the 1950s and that is making hit records
and singing so I'm thrilled for him
really am and the fans have stayed with
him the fat all the fans have stayed I
mean I don't know whether you went to
the Albert Hall last year but cliff
could hardly start singing because
people stood up at the beginning just to
me a fact that he was there and that's a
great sign that people love him and
they're very Lord and anyway the British
audiences are very loyal and I and I
think that that you know everybody in
terms of the fan club and everything saw
through all of that and just really felt
sorry that Cliff were subjected to it
because it's a lot to subject anybody to
and it has been tough and you've been
open and saying that but now I thank
goodness this is a good night he's a
good man and it's going to be a good
future so it's good all the way we
couldn't speak earlier on when I asked
the question just about how tougher that
been for him personally but from a
friends perspective looking in from the
outside you never doubted them you know
how did it feel as a friend seeing
someone go through all of that for so
much because I happen to be watching
television the day that the police and
the BBC went helicopters above going
into his house and I couldn't it was
like a movie really you couldn't believe
that this was actuality but I knew the
apartment and I knew that this was real
it was
and in fact I rang cliff I'm in minutes
afterward to say are you watching TV
because you know this is just
unbelievable
and clearly I can't talk about any
lawsuit there Clippers is carrying on
the minute but i reaiiy would walk to
dine in street with him as we walk this
red carpet to get the law change because
i think that law has to be changed so
that people you know are not named until
there's a charge made a message for the
fans the people who stayed with you
through the most difficult of your life
well I don't think they never understand
how much their love for me means I know
that the love between an artist and fans
is this difference between our husband
and the wife or brother and sister but
it's a love and I've appreciated all the
fantastic messages I've received it's
helped bolster my faith as well I do
believe that God has a part to play in
the fact that I'm still here and people
still like me it's a miracle to me after
all these years so bless you all thank
you